conservatives are fuming over the
president's latest move on immigration
the department of homeland security
issued new rules on deportation saying
being in the country illegally should
not be the sole basis for being sent
home all this comes as a new caravan
makes its way north and the immigration
braces for 400 000 migrants coming to
the southern border republicans are
calling the president out
we have a border crisis there has been
over 1.5 million illegal border
crossings so far under president biden
small towns at our southern border are
overwhelmed by migrants march was the
largest month on record for illegal
crossings until april april was the
largest month until may until june june
until july when 212 000 illegal migrants
encounters on our border um this is this
is a complete disaster but it's it's all
to feed of joe biden in his
administration
now daggett um this new rule which was
like the zero tolerance when it comes to
how ice immigration might sort of
deports folks um was created under the
trump administration and it's gotten a
lot it's caught up it's got a lot of
folks caught up one individual in
particular was a seven-year army vet who
served this country who was deported so
some people there's reasons for some
people to say this is a good rule or
it's a bad rule but oftentimes there are
people who get caught up in the melee
that served this country like this
particular individual who was here who
served for seven years and then got
deported back to mexico now trying to
get his way back in the country after
serving in our armed forces so how do we
sort of bridge the gap between
yes and no right because the answer's
someplace probably in the middle well
this directive is is beyond just one
individual it includes it here it says
it argues against deporting an illegal
immigrant who has committed a crime
say if you're of a tender age or an
advanced age
it goes on if you're in this country
illegally by that very word you've
broken the law number one and there's
great pressure now being put on the bite
administration from the far left because
they actually deep deported some of the
haitians that came into this country and
now they're upset you know people
camping out in front of alejandro
mayorkas house with anyone being
deported but let's say okay how about
let's start caring about the fentanyl
that's crossing the border our resources
are
being sucked up by hundreds of thousands
of people coming into the country and
you've got well we talked about it
yesterday 93 000 people died from
fentanyl poisonings how about the left
starts caring about the loved ones and
the families and the dead because our
border isn't being protected
and just one more thing on this
i i this will only and jesse everybody
can win this will only make this crisis
worse when they're planning on four
hundred thousand people hitting the
border this month
jesse your take
i think you and i are gonna agree on
something richard
whoa all right cameras are only because
you can't disagree with this
if you know that in june the
pandamanians tipped off sleepy and said
hey we got about 10 000 strong caravana
haitians coming up through
panama into central america into your
country and they didn't do anything
about it and then
in october
late september they tell you you know
what it's going to go to about 400 000
strong caravan coming up now we're a
sophisticated country richard we have
satellite technology we have station
chiefs all over that region we have
diplomats
how long do you think it takes to get
from colombia all the way to the rio
grande probably a couple months right
five months so you're seeing it happen
in real time so joe has what maybe
several months
warning you have 400 000 migrants okay
do you think joe biden could do anything
anything at all richard to stop or even
slow down
400 000 migrants coming from
south america to north america do you
think he has anything
you know in his tool chest to figure
that out no actually okay so you agree
you agree dude now my next question do
you think he will do anything about that
i think he should i he you think he
should i think he should but i don't
think he will and that's why the
president is in over his head
because he will not do anything about
this so will you yield for a question so
i will give you that will you then say
that we have 11 million folks in this
country living in the shadows probably
20 million they've been using 11 million
since i was in diapers fair enough
should we do something about them or
should we just deport all of them no i
take out the criminals best i could you
know the hardcore ones
it's very difficult to get the ones that
haven't committed a crime very difficult
but i'd get everybody else out and then
what should we do i'd deport them all 11
million or just the criminals i'd get
all the nasty ones out and then when i
get them out faster the other ones
what should i do with the other ones i
don't think i'd put them on a pathway
okay i don't think i would i actually
agree that i think citizenship is sacred
but i don't think we have proper legal
means to deal with people here who are
working hard paying taxes and raising
families and as for the people who've
made their way from columbia through
panama there's a 65 mile stretch called
the darien gap which is so incredibly
treacherous and they all have to go
through it there are black panthers
there are pit vipers there are scorpions
there is there are massive swaths of
jungle so if people are literally going
to put themselves
in
death's clutches to get to the united
states they're probably going to be some
pretty badass people so we need to have
better means of figuring out good people
from bad people the federal government
to your point at the top of the show has
been really really bad at doing that
every administration republican democrat
they don't want to deal with immigration
congress doesn't want to deal with
immigration they don't want to figure
out the laws that are stupid and
redundant from the ones that might be
helpful getting people in who want to
work hard and make this country better
i'm sure we all have people in our
family who came here from a different
place with a big fat dream i still think
there are a lot of people like that but
i think the government has failed them
utterly every step of the way especially
this administration and shame on them
for not actually doing something about
it when they have the majority in
congress as well
this is only one of those conversations
that happens amongst liberals who are
generally like clueless nonsensical
dopes a lot like this is a serious
conversation on the present company sue
but this is of course a conversation on
the left like
should be in the country illegally be
the only reason we deport people for
being in the country illegally you're
like let's change the topic for a minute
to make this make sense to liberals
because they're generally dunces should
we arrest people for crack and the only
reason being we arrested for crack
because they smoke crack and you're like
oh this is a crime do you understand
like you want to deport people for
illegal immigration and you're wondering
if that's the only reason to deport them
all right you're getting like am i crazy
you can't just stay in other countries
anyway wait wait wait the dhs
is seriously serious suggesting you
can't deport people